hey everyone and welcome welcome to part
three of this battery saving video
series so what we're going to do in this
part is we're going to discuss discuss
actually a number of battery saving tips
um that i've discovered so first of all
what we're going to do is turn off
wireless i know you might think well
that sounds kind of stupid but the first
thing people people are usually using
when they find that they need to
maximize their battery life maybe
they're just listening to music maybe
they're just on an airplane maybe
they're just chilling in their room just
messing around with their computer i
don't know what they're doing so what
they got to do is disable um
if they don't have their power supply
next next to them or near them disable
um or should i say
turn off wireless so wireless is
basically what's constantly searching
for and also bluetooth by the way so
wireless if you have a switch on your
computer it's what's basically
constantly searching for emails
constantly searching for a signal if you
have thunderbird it's obviously always
checking downloading emails constantly
your virus scans are running on the
emails that are being um
searched into your computer
so um as these things are being stored
at your computer your computer has to
process them and that's using your
processor so turning wireless off will
save you a lot of battery life um
actually a lot more than you might think
even more than disabling windows aero
and using a bigger battery really
so
disabling wireless is the number one
thing that i recommend and i'll show you
how to do that in the software coming up
don't worry i always do that so number
two what we're going to do is cut down
the use of external devices
external devices being say a mouse or
maybe an external drive maybe you have
a flash drive like this one
um maybe you have one of these for your
mouse that hooks up to your wireless
mouse i did a review on my mouse
so things like that if the more of these
that you have uh hooked up to your
computer the more battery you're gonna
use
um
so that that definitely drains your
battery so remove them or shut them down
when you're not using them so if you're
just on your lap and you're not actually
using your mouse yes you can go ahead
and unplug that mouse usb
now one of my later videos is inevitably
going to contradict this because i'm
going to end up recommending a laptop
cooler for you guys which is going to
run on usb
but
that's another tip for helping windows
run faster as well as
helping your computer last longer so
it's not necessarily going to make your
battery life better but i guarantee you
that removing wireless devices um
and removing usb devices and external
hard drives and stuff when you're just
moving when you're just chilling and you
have
one battery that's going to help you
guys a lot
and i'm i'm pretty sure i said three
things so i'm going to say the last
thing is
to not use to just remove any disk from
your cd drive so you might have noticed
when you open up my computer and you go
click on my computer your hard drive
starts spinning a little bit or your um
your processing light on your laptop
comes on
and that might seem a little unusual but
really it's searching for everything
that's new that might have been added
may have been added to your computer
since you last clicked on the my
computer button
so really what you want to do is remove
um just hit that eject button on the
side of your computer or just you know
whatever you go into your windows and
eject it right click on it and eject
that disk all the disks that are in
there
trust me spinning the disk constantly is
going to use a lot of battery so
the less hard drive you use the less usb
devices you use and the less wireless
activity you do is going to they're all
going to add up to increase the battery
life of your computer so i hope this was
tutorial i hope this tutorial was
helpful to you guys and um i think i'm
just going to do a quick a quick little
software um edit after this to show you
guys exactly how to do a few of the
things i just showed you
so um thanks for watching this was
number three and enjoy the software
peace
all right the first thing i told you
guys on my camera was to um remove all
your usb or actually the second thing
but to remove all your usb devices now
what you want to do if you are if you
haven't already known there will be a
little icon down here um let me just
oh let me just plug one in for you i'm
gonna i'm gonna plug in a usb device in
a second and you're gonna see a little
pop-up window saying you know you have a
usb device plugged in
exit out
all right guys once this is plugged in
and you will expand your system tray
right here and you'll see this little
green icon with a check coming on it but
pardon the pardon that blinking so i'll
expand this again and you'll see this
little icon with a check i'm going to
right click on that and there's only one
option that comes up that says safely
remove hardware go ahead and click that
option
a little window will come up and
hopefully it'll come up soon and here we
go it'll say i have a usb storage device
all you have to do is hit stop
okay
and boom it's it's safely removable from
your computer so i just put it out right
there so the usb device is gone that
will save you guys some battery
so the second thing that i was going to
tell you guys was to um
to turn off wireless easy on my computer
because there's a wireless switch but if
you have this right here in windows
vista there is a little network icon in
your system tray double click on it and
hit connect your disconnect and another
window will obviously pop up just hit
that disconnect button right there
and last but not least remove any
devices from your hard from your disk so
i'm going to go into my computer
and i'll just put open here
and there are no devices in my usb drive
if there was i would right click on it
and hit the eject button
of course it just pops out an empty tray
so that's all i got to show you guys for
today hope you enjoyed this hd tutorial
and subscribe for more thanks for
watching and subscribe peace